[Risas]
[Música]
sobre todo porque creo que la la primera
pregunta me preocupa por lo siguiente
creo que cada vez que hay una situación
de este tipo estamos en la era de la
comunicación
el exceso de comunicación lo cual no
significa estar bien informados o
informadas entonces es muy común en
estos días en estar buscando en internet
síntomas o indicadores de malestar
que mi experiencia por lo menos es que
la mayor parte de la gente cuando nos
pasa para muchas de vosotras pero vamos
a mí en lo médico me pasa que si quiera
buscar información sobre una enfermedad
acabó creyendo que tengo todo lo que
acabo alimento entonces yo creo que hay
una parte que tenemos que partir de la
normalidad estamos en una situación
atípica estamos en una situación que no
hemos elegido tener y que nos ha sido
impuesta con un miedo a una consecuencia
de lo que puede pasar por tanto sólo por
eso y ya es normal tener ciertos
síntomas de malestar psicológico sólo
por eso es una situación atípica vale
eso qué significa
hay un estudio que se publicó en la
revista the lancet
sobre el sars en el 2002 en canadá y los
autores
brooks y colaboradores encontraron que
por ejemplo un aislamiento o
confinamiento está pasando que duren más
de 10 días y ya tiene consecuencias
psicológicas sí o sí en la población
estamos hablando de que de pequeñas
muestras se da señales de que el
funcionamiento no es el más adecuado por
ejemplo siempre vemos las necesidades
básicas en el dormir el insomnio puede
ser un indicador el dormir nos tarde o
la somnolencia en horas que no nos
corresponde tener estados de nuestros
sueños el comer demasiado o el no comer
bueno es decir cuando de repente ante el
aburrimiento empieza a comer demasiado o
no me entra la comida y tercero la
digestión el líder al baño no irá al
baño ya sé que pues es poco
políticamente correcto pero son los
indicadores dónde vamos viendo que en
nuestro culto no se está diciendo
quiénes ajustes que algunos están
funcionando bien
eso es para pedir ayuda yo creo que de
entrada yo creo que de entrada es normal
vale al igual que la falta de motivación
para hacer cosas lo que llamamos los
psicólogos la anhedonia la falta de
motivación de hacer cosas que antes nos
podían gustar es normal vale porque
porque estamos una situación que nos ha
desorganizado
a mí me gusta una frase que es cuando la
versión de ti mismo te empiezan a gustar
cuando te ves en el espejo es decir
cuando ves que el carácter que te sale
con tu pareja que el carácter que te
sale con tus hijos o hijas que la forma
de estar en el día a día no es la
versión
qué más te pueda mostrar de ti mismo
aunque se acerca a ser aceptado por ti
mismo empiece a plantearte que algo
estaba ocurriendo en cómo te estás
sintiendo por eso en el confinamiento es
imprescindible el contacto con otras
personas porque tenemos el ojo desde
afuera de alguien que nos están viendo
nos está diciendo otras existen es cómo
estás cómo te encuentras
el mayor peligro que yo creo que hay son
los pensamientos en otros pensamientos
se quedan todos en la cabeza en el
momento que expresamos lo que pensamos
hay un otro que al escucharlo nos puede
dar su feedback si solo estamos con
nuestros propios pensamientos es donde
generalmente vamos a encontrar
indicadores donde ese estrés esa
ansiedad se va a empezar a manifestar de
otra manera acuerdo si luego nos da
tiempo podríamos hablar yo creo que una
relación interesante con el tema de las
fases del duelo nos da que cada persona
reacciona de una manera diferente
quizás esto está relacionado con la
segunda pregunta que me hacías de cómo
podemos animar vale porque vamos a pasar
por diferentes etapas vamos a pasar por
etapas que nos sentimos fuerte para
animar y etapas en los que necesitamos
ser animados o sea animadas
a mí me gusta a veces plantear la
siguiente metáfora no hay dos tipos de
personas personas mosca y personas
mariposa
las personas mosca son las que en un
campo lleno de flores acaban encontrando
la única que existe y las
personas mariposas son aquellas que en
un campo lleno de acaban
encontrando la única flor que existe
entonces en el día a día por mucho que
leamos de psicología por mucho que
leamos deporte hace ejercicio porque
además hay algo que tenemos que ver cómo
estamos nosotras o nosotros si no
estamos bien no estás en disposición de
ayudar a otros porque porque al final
nos estamos convirtiendo por ejemplo en
padres de nuestros padres como estamos
preocupados por su edad y por el conavi
lo que sí estamos llamando siete veces
al día como ellos hacían con nosotros
cuando éramos adolescentes por lo tanto
ahí no estamos ayudando estamos comiendo
una necesidad nuestra que no es nuestra
preocupación entonces tenemos que medir
muy bien qué
[Música]
apoyo el comentarios positivos el humor
tomarse un poco esto de cierta forma
relativa tenemos que ver si es necesidad
nuestra o del otro entonces para poder
ayudar al otro primero temas de producto
que necesita ser había la metáfora que
me suele gustar que es la metáfora del
pozo que yo en psicología tenemos que
trabajar mucho que cuando a quien está
en el pozo hay tres formas de reaccionar
puedes pasar de largo conmigo esto no va
no quiero saber nada en la segunda de
dónde te metes al pozo para sacar esa
persona de ahí entonces hay que sacar a
dos porque a ver cómo sabes y la tercera
es en la que echas la cuerda a tienes
esa persona y si esa persona se agarra
tiras y le ayudas a subir es un trabajo
bidireccional el otro se tiene que
agarrar y tú tienes que tirar de la
cuerda por lo tanto yo creo que en este
momento es importante que diferenciamos
cuando necesitamos ayudar al otro porque
no sólo es porque lo necesita y dos que
es lo que necesita
le propongo de ayudar es nuestra enzima
es nuestra llamando es nuestra ración de
bromas hay que ajustar a cada situación
y esto es difícil vale porque conlleva
empatizar con el otro y una situación de
crisis a veces nosotros tampoco estamos
en disposición de hacerlo
claro si esto lo relacionas con la
tercera pregunta que hacías de cómo lo
hacemos con todo lo que es el número que
es lo que decirlo a mí me está matando
el estrés
hablamos del síndrome macgyver navaja
suiza en donde en este momento esto
hemos tenido que afrontar en el mismo
confinamiento en 70 metros cuadrados 80
metros cuadrados porque a mí me parece
guay cuando serán los futbolistas
hablando de quédate en casa ningún
futbolista porque es uno de los ejemplos
no programa por la piscina enorme con
gimnasio con tres plantas yo me enfado
con mi mujer y nos tenemos trazado por
el bar así así como los que no saben si
en un duelo de alguien dispara primero
es muy difícil esto de cómo compaginar
ser pareja sea el padre o ser madre o
incluso estaba solo porque tenemos que
compaginar montón de tareas toque llamar
a mis padres como es tanto que pronto
por los amigos es decir lo que al
principio era algo divertido entre
comillas de conectar el whatsapp un
montón de gente se está como de una
situación muy estresante
yo la metáfora con la que estoy
trabajando estos días con un encuentro
con gente que me llama con esto es que
haz de tu casa la metáfora del mundo en
el que vivías antes es decir ahora
nuestro micro sistema es el hogar es la
casa entonces a veces el tener un
espacio que sea el de trabajo otro
espacio que sea de familia otro espacio
que sea de diversión y no me refiero una
casa grande sino que el momento que
compartimos ese espacio es para que
tarea
es muy importante la normalidad
estructural del día como si con un día
cotidiano no vivir como si fuéramos
todos días en domingo lo explico
es decir materias ciertos horarios de la
estructura cotidiana que no tenga
alcohol es el mantener en un horario
rituales de transición por ejemplo si
tengo que trabajar cuando termine de
trabajar y salga por la puerta dejó mi
trabajo en la puerta cual es el ritual
colocó la bata me doy una ducha vale
tenemos que crear rituales de transición
entre tarea y tarea si es posible pero
todo esto de psicología general en cada
caso es totalmente diferente
porque alguien que vive solo tiene que
afrontar de una manera muy diferente que
alguien que tenga familia numerosa o que
tenga gente a su cargo por ejemplo
por lo tanto yo creo que hay
parte generalmente me suele gustar en
esa idea es cómo distribuir los roles de
las tareas que tenemos que hacer y hay
una cuestión clara tenemos que aceptar
que lo vamos a hacer mal
para mí es imprescindible la vamos a
acabar nos vamos a equivocar nos vamos a
frustrar nos vamos a enfadar y eso está
dentro de lo normal si no es imposible
convivir con la situación que tenemos en
este momento porque esa situación
artificial vale entonces tengo que
construir esta casa como nuestro micro
mundo de alguna manera
[Música]
a